Australia ha decidido dejar de reconocer
a Jerusalén oeste como capital de Israel
y esto ha desatado una tormenta
diplomática el gobierno del laborista
Anthony albanese Diego marcha atrás con
la medida tomada por el conservador
Scott Morrison en 2018 suministra de
exteriores defendió que sidney retoma
así el consenso Internacional de que el
estatus de Jerusalén debe resolverse en
negociaciones de paz entre Israel y el
pueblo palestino recordemos de que la
coalición liberal Nacional de Morrison
siguió los pasos del ex presidente
estadounidense de Donald Trump que en
2017 rompió con la postura internacional
al reconocer a Jerusalén como capital
israelí y mudar aquí la Embajada de
Estados Unidos la respuesta israelí no
se ha hecho esperar el Ministerio de
exteriores se calificó al revés
australiano de decepción y citó a
consultas al embajador Paul griffith
Mientras que el Primer Ministro Jair
lapiz acusó Australia de falta de
seriedad y de reaccionar a un informe
incorrecto de los medios haciendo
referencia al anticipo de The Guardian
sobre intercambio de lenguaje que se
registró en las páginas oficiales del
gobierno australiano del otro lado la
cartera de exteriores de la autoridad
Palestina celebró la corrección positiva
de Australia algo que fue seguido por
Indonesia país vecinos de Australia y
que tiene mayoría musulmana Jerusalén
este que los palestinos reclaman como la
capital de Su futuro estado fue ocupada
por Israel en 1967 y han hecho nada en
1980 un movimiento no reconocido por la
comunidad internacional lo que llevó a
decenas de países a mudar sus embajadas
a Tel aviv actualmente en esta ciudad
Santa se encuentran solo las embajadas
de Estados Unidos Guatemala Honduras y
kosovo y hay expectativa Por la
intención de la nueva primera ministra
británica listras de trasladar la sede
consular a Jerusalén una voluntad que ya
ha recibido críticas de las
instituciones palestinas